[Musique]
phénomène de la scène pop des années 70
et 80 freddie mercury leader du groupe
queen est devenu une icône en ajoutant
de l'opéra aux guitares électriques et
en assumant son homosexualité
flamboyante avant de mourir du sida en
1991 bryan singer vie rend hommage dans
un biopic arabes se dit du nom de l'un
de ses plus célèbres titres et pour
incarner le performeur incroyable
d'origine iranienne singer a choisi le
jeune acteur américain d'origine
égyptienne rami malek révélée par la
série mr bottes
sa composition est absolument
hallucinante marié ouais moi je dois
dire qu'il m'a beaucoup plu dans
d'autant que voilà le film a été très
compliqué cette reviendra sur les
aventures de production du film et que
longtemps on a attendu sacha baron cohen
dans le rôle et j'ai on l'attendait avec
un peu d'impatience c'est vrai que ton a
vu débarquer rallier mal est donc plus
connu pour avoir été révélée par la
série mr bottes bombay 2 où on faisait
un peu comme ça et puis il se fait
beaucoup beaucoup
comment dire aux critiques et que le
film un accueil tiède on va dire et moi
même je pense que je serai un peu seul
aujourd'hui on va voir à voir et
localiser des haies et le côté très
critiquée ca voilà on lui a mis une
prothèse alors comme si deux prothèses
de fausses dents dont comme si ça
suffisait à incarner freddie mercury
moi je trouve qu'il se sent super bien
physiquement du rôle notamment dans les
séquences de concert où il arriva a
évidemment c'est vraiment rare c'est le
biopic de chez biopic de chez biopic
c'est à dire c'est le blick officielle
qui portent l'imprimatur des survivants
de queen et c'est un biopic fondée sur
le mimétisme est sûre rejouer des trucs
alors parmi les séquences clés de cette
une pied pendant toute la première
partie une franche comédie un voile à
eybens et montrer comment sont nés les
grands tubes de queen
donc voilà le fameux galileo de bohemian
rhapsody et tout est facile tout est
drôle tout à la freddy mercury atouts
dans sa tête la création n'est jamais un
problème ça n'est jamais
torture et comment on accouche d'un tube
et comment on sait que le tube sera bon
et ben voilà il ya un petit truc de
montage vous allez voir c'est qu'après
on voit le résultat
sur scène on est en 75 voilà regardez
les tenues évidemment extravagantes de
freddie mercury le côté cueillir dans
queens
bien évidemment et le film s'offre
beaucoup de séquences de faux live parce
que c'est pas rami malek qui chante
c'est vraiment bien la voix de freddie
mercury et donc le film est très
déconcertant parce que c'est une comédie
un peu un peu lourdingue mais pas
désagréable pendant un long moment ça
vire un peu au drame
c'est très chronologique et surtout il
ya 20 minutes à la fin où ils rejouent
le concerne le live de wembley ça c'est
extraordinaire
le meilleur avec une émission incroyable
j'ai pleuré à tous les films du serbe
s'assure cette semaine ils me prennent
forme pas pour les mêmes raisons
alors nicolas je me tourne vers vous
quelle image de queen et ce qu'il donne
une radiographie dentaire non pardon
c'est une blague
non évidemment comme le dit marie et
comme il faut aussi être un peu énorme
déception parce qu'on sait moi je suis
fan de memory plaisir énorme déception
t'attendais à quoi non mais j'ai alors
je bats ou sais pas sur quoi je
m'attendais je m'attendais à quelque
chose de mieux que ça en tout cas non je
vais vous dire pourquoi énorme déception
énorme déception parce que c'est
complètement bryan singer arrive quand
même quelque chose un tour de force
magistral c'est de dévitaliser la vie de
freddie mercury dévitalisées la der de
l'asept ise complètement
c'est un peu comme si on voulait faire
une biographie ou un biopic de mick
jagger en se concentrant sur sa passion
pour le plâtre si vous voulez c'est à
peu près le même genre de système et
freddie mercury kaka mais une vie
extrêmement complexe les crémants riche
et bien tous les enjeux dramatiques du
personnage autour de sa sexualité sa
bisexualité son problème à s'assumer la
drogue la maladie tous à ces évacués
dans des espèces de petites séquences de
quelques secondes vous savez ces
séquences clip et qu'on met dans les
films à la pretty woman pop
il arrive où il critique et humaine qui
n'ira jamais vous voyez bien cesser ces
corps ce clip et ça grouille a que de la
musique où il ya plus de dialogue et
peuvent ils rentrent dans un club
peuvent vous voit un monsieur en
moustache en cuir et peuvent ça y est on
a résolu le problème de sa sexualité du
sida non enfin c'est quand même
l'assassinât mais sérieux
compliquant leur big officiel de queen
tu t'attends à des séquences et bien
pleine
non mais c'est bien le problème blague
est bien le problème de l'officialité du
biopic puisque effectivement ça a été
commandée par les survivants du groupe
comme tu l'as dit l' avantage alors on
peut voir le détail ça c'est que
effectivement on a les vrais
enregistrement de freddie mercury
donc ça pour la musique pour le son
c'est formidable et effectivement rami
malek sauve un peu ce qui a sauvé du
film dans son interprétation pour dire
juste un mot de la toute fin du concert
du live aid pour une fois d'un seul coup
il donne un enjeu à ce personnage qui va
jouer quelque chose de sa vie de sa
carrière dont ce concert et laramy mal
act est là quelque chose interpréter et
il ya eu l'idée de signer mal si là il
ya du soleil tout à fait on dit c'est un
film de bryan singer n'est pas tout à
fait un hasard que c'est à 85% un film
de ratzinger il n'a pas fini parce qu'il
ya eu un conflit enfin il ya eu
énormément de conflit et il a été
remercié sur le plateau après ton xiring
il restait 15 % du film à tourner cet
exemple les gens qui a fini après il ya
un argue un arrangement juridique qui
fait que bryan singer est le seul
signataire en tant que de la mise en
scène dans le générique et bien pas dans
le cercle benoît xvi de bryan singer et
dexter fletcher est au cinéma
allez-y à pleins poumons allez-y